une vingtaine de militants ont suivi le
premier débat de la primaire à la
permanence de benoît hamon attrape ce
jeudi 12 janvier une série d'échangés
entre les candidats attendus par les
principaux soutiens du député yves
binois a plutôt sera donc en peine qui
se passe très très bien depuis le début
de lancement de campagne au mois d'août
avec une montée en puissance régulière
des nouveaux contacts des nouveaux
militants qui rejoint de la campagne
l'idée c'est de montrer la cohérence de
son projet et qu'il a une perspective
pour la france qui est bien ancré à
gauche
donc s'il arrive à faire passer des
éléments sur son programme pour la
france dans les années qui viennent et
qui permettent aux gens de gauche de se
projeter et de leur donner envie de
venir en primaires votées il aura gagné
revenu universel sécurité sociale
fiscalité différents axes des programmes
des sept candidats
benoît hamon souhaite élaborer un revenu
de base une position divergente avec ses
concurrents notamment sur la capacité
pour l'état à financer ce dispositif un
sentiment de confiance avait plus de
fierté pour notre candidat qui est entré
démontré des idées nouvelles et on voit
bien que les débats tournaient autour de
ses idées
le député des yvelines a aussi abordé
lors de ce débat les questions
institutionnelles et critiqué la loi
travail
il a ravi les militants de sa
circonscription on espère qu'ils seront
tous réunis avant pouvoir et se
réuniront en avoir quelque chose de
concret
à faire ensemble et de gagner ensemble
génial il a dû tout ce que je voulais je
voulais attendre surtout le chômage et
la précarité la parler une zad
d'étrangers une satisfaction des
soutiens de benoît hamon à confirmer
lors des prochains débats des primaires
citoyennes